but i think it's interesting too the
thing about where politics has taken
over culture because at a certain point
all of the creators and the artists
started saying that you had to be
activist in your art and they were all
leftist so everything you saw on tv
started being like you know far left
political bias messaging on purpose it's
exhausting it's exhausting
bad art it makes really crappy viewing i
have no tv i barely partake in anything
in society more it's not fun nothing's
fun there's always the message and
everything you're watching and you're
like are you serious like
ugh i don't know i'm rejecting girl
power admittedly buried in video games
for the last like
maybe but i cannot take what are you
playing i've been playing warcraft every
day
warcraft uh
like world of warcraft
sir yeah the ultimate escapism it's like
because i cannot watch movies or stupid
i can't take gum acting i can't take
politics there's this like political
like it's not that i don't like
politics in general i don't like
partisan crap where i'm getting fed a
narrative
to to push some agenda i can't it
doesn't interest me it doesn't entertain
me so i'm buried in in like escapism
it's but this is this is what happens
you're right you know at some point the
activists were like everything is
political so everything needs to be and
it was the left doing that and this is a
this was combined with the the advent of
these microblogs that focus specifically
on one issue so if you're a gaming
website this this is why i think
gamergate was like the first big culture
war battle if you're a gaming website
how often can you really write an
article a new video game comes out so
you do all the walkthroughs you give all
your thoughts in the new game designs
you do a couple reviews now what you
gotta watch streamers yeah they should
be doing games
they say
the game's racist
oh dead video games right let's talk
about that bill gates bought warcraft
and i had to sign a social
contract like some woke thing to play
with wow yeah they're like you can't
tell people they're naughty names when
they're not doing what they're supposed
to do in a raid and i'm like what like i
can't be
like on i guess it's discord now i'm so
old i almost said ben trillo and be like
yeah i'm like
what you can't yell at people and call
them names i'm like that's like what
world of warcraft is all about they
ruined it but so what happens is
the the response to these these woke
lunatics was the anti-woke people
challenging it but they were reactive
these are the people trying to escape
ian and the reason why the culture war
started is because people who are just
like dude i don't want politics i'm just
trying to get away from work and the
news i just want to fight some goblins
and all of a sudden the goblins are
telling me i'm being racist for fighting
the goblins why is this happening and
then they found out that there were
certain prominent feminists who were
going to video game companies and
telling you had to do this and then this
whole thing has just snowballed and it's
continued to the point where now we have
esg i saw a video i'll see if i can pull
it up and explain it later but this guy
was saying that if you if you affect
the children and you make them you
sexually compromise children that they
lose their will
and then as adults they're unable to
combat
anything well they have no boundaries so
you can introduce almost anything to an
abused child like that's why everyone's
anti-grooming right now and that happens
though i mean it's interesting some of
the early drag queen story hour videos
that i saw of like you know parents
bringing their kids the kids would there
were a couple of videos where i saw the
kids would like be pushed toward the
drag queen which is basically like a man
in garish makeup and a dress and a beard
it's sort of like confusing for a kid
the kid would be pushed towards it the
person and then you know would try and
turn away and the parents would push the
kid back you know like it's like saying
break down your did you break down your
barriers you see the video of the old
man in tighty whities twerking to a
little girl
the woman walks up and waves to him and
tells the little girl a little girl
waves to him yeah it looks like he
pooped in them too like he was such a
wreck i i want to uh i want so i want
that clip i want to try and get
i'm going to i want to pitch it out to
all the big uh
advertising billboards
and i was like hey would you guys be
okay putting like a pride event video
clip up and say yes but here's the clip
the problem is i don't own it and so
apparently the person who owns it is
very pro what they filmed
so we need video footage of that that's
not that like we could buy or license or
claim or something the video is by this
guy named jocko bullion's first time
ever some was a prageru video on
instagram no no no the original video
the original video was was someone at
pride celebrating pride oh i'm sorry i
was referencing the guy talking about
sexually compromising children
willingness to fight and willingness to
support the free speech willingness to
be even interested they're just
incapable of of understanding the rights
of others when you when you're broken
mentally especially sexually broken i
didn't it didn't happen to me so i don't
personally see it but i see it in others
where it happened to them and it's very
difficult to to continue and to like
know what your boundaries are i yeah i
mean i have friends where this
this is their background and they have
an extremely difficult time with
relationships with understanding what
it's okay to do to them or not
you know i'll just throw out it's very
disturbing and it's hard for them to
to go through life with that i've had
over 20 years of therapy i was molested
when i was a kid and i married a guy
that was over 25 years older than me it
has a profound effect on kids and he
happened to be the same age as the dude
that you know
so think it does stuff to you dude and
of course when you're young you're like
no it didn't i'm fine and then you're
sitting on the couch like i'm not i
don't care
oh i'm totally okay now
i want that to happen to people you know
yeah but it does and then everyone
celebrates it on twitter look at this
look at what they're doing with these
kids this is great it's acceptance i
think what we're seeing with the
internet and with the start of the
culture war is it's like a sorting
algorithm the people of weak mental
fortitude of weak will are just
shuffling along whichever direction and
they're being shuffled off the cliff and
then the people of strong of strong will
and mental fortitude are resistant and
saying no and that's probably why it's
apolitical why there are liberal people
who are now hanging out with
conservatives and voting for donald
trump and being called french and being
called short yeah yeah yeah that's the
world most people agree with these these
opinions
but if you're in the cult and you're of
weak will then you're gonna see someone
on the tv say mean things just say
that's a fact period no matter what you
know it's been my experience like i have
friends family that voted for biden and
i never say a word to them i don't like
reprimand them or tell them they're
stupid or but the second someone finds
out i voted for trump but here it comes
and i'm like well biden's just as
horrible like to me and i'm not like
being a butthole to you what like what
is wrong with humanity anymore
they can't just be cool with each other
if
look there are some sane people on the
left but it's the it's the exception not
the rule and that's because uh so i was
i was actually uh talking with some
other prominent uh personality this
morning about strategy and stuff and and
they were asking me about you know left
and right and i said look man we talked
about this on the show
uh the right if you look on blind
spotter typically are people who have
balanced views
the left is echo chamber biased cult
they claim the right is the cult but
then you look at ben shapiro and it's
like left and right wing you know on his
blind spot or whatever he consumes news
from all sources he is not in an echo
chamber he is not blind to the facts
like you were mentioning you listen to
npr and do all these things these
journalists in nbc exclusively left-wing
source is not a single right-wing source
and then they post insane things on
twitter totally devoid of facts and they
believe jesse smellet right dude you
know i got flamed on when that story
first came out we're both from
chicagoland i read that story and i'm
like no one goes and walks outside in
that weather no way the gang bangers are
inside smoke and they're and it was it
was by nbc and the clock never there's
like no humans there never like even
when you're drunk you're not like bro oh
negative 40 polar vortex let's go to
subway said no one in shy town let alone
this is mega country that is not mag
country
and then i said it and everyone's like
you're you're a racist i'm like what how
am i racist like i
from there i know this and then it came
out
not a single person said they were sorry
but man did i get executed
all of these stories this is what i like
to bring up you know we can go through
the list of every story that was fake
they believe it every single time well
and then they then they
claim to be arbiters of misinformation
disinformation and truth while they're
the ones who have been pushing this
stuff out there like there was a whole
political story a politico ran a story
and then everybody else picked it up
saying that clarence thomas made these
um claims about code coveted vaccines oh
yeah and he didn't yes he he didn't at
all in his descent of not taking this
case i think he wanted to take the case
i might be wrong about that but he was
talking about how what the
people who were bringing the suit said
he said what they said he was quoting
them and everyone was like clarence
thomas is making fake news you know fake
uh
and even when assumptions about it at
first they said clarence thomas posts
false claim x then when they realized
that it was him quoting the the the
plaintiffs i believe he they then change
it to clarence thomas pushes claim of x
and it's like uh he had to cite their
claim in his dissent right like could he
have just not put what they were arguing
he needed to like it's just it just
happened uh this happened all through
universities in the past few years as
well like a professor would use a word
in order to discuss the word uh usually
it would be like the n word for example
a professor would use
say the word in order to discuss the
word and then would have a whole bunch
of backlash because they were it was
believed that they had used the word but
you have to be able to say a word in
order to discuss it although as regards
the the pride footage you were talking
about we actually had a ton of that
footage that was taken by um beth baish
in toronto and also in um katie davis
court in seattle with a ton of stuff
that video specifically the one of the
old man twerking for the little girl it
was so cool we have like all these naked
people doing stuff boyfriend of kids in
front of kids
the issue the issue with that one is
you get a naked person and you go to an
advertiser they'll say look it doesn't
matter nudity is not allowed okay okay
well but i got his underwear bikini
models are allowed absolutely so
what what this video is particularly
interesting that shows his old man
twerking in front of a little girl
because one it's in public so it is not
considered to be
out of the bounds of what is publicly
acceptable the man is fully clothed he's
wearing tighty whities you can't tell me
that he's doing anything illegal or if
they say that's not a lot i'll be like
why you have women in bikinis you have
men in speedos but this guy's not
allowed because they know it would be
bad bad bad if they actually did it
imagine times square on the beast a
70-foot screen the biggest you just have
that video everybody would would vote
republican in two seconds if they
watched that what happened to our
society like 10 years ago if some old
dude twerked in front of your kid that
dude would not be alive like that would
not be acceptable for people to like
parade and twerk and shimmy in front of
kids and now everyone's like bring the
kids on down for the shimmy facts and
that came out that was in the the
washington post a couple years ago ran
an article about why kink is good to
expose kids it's disgusting
look we're seeing geographic
hyperpolarization people in the cities
who oppose that stuff are leaving the
cities and the people who like it or are
weak willed are just sitting there
saying like yeah whatever i don't care
so we're watching these videos and going
how could this be happening it's because
everybody of sound mind is leaving these
areas they're going to texas and they're
going to florida in droves
for good reason and the outer suburbs
and we went to west virginia
all my gay friends are like we don't do
the pride anything like they're like we
used to on the weekend like 10 years ago
hey we had a little week and they're
like it has just turned into debauchery
and you know like i can be gay without a
community of people like good job but my
bad is funny
oh man this is more babies this is why i
say stuff like uh
like civil war because people don't
understand the world views are so
incredibly divergent that you you people
like people
can't live together anymore so
from what i've seen in my own eyes i
went to northern ireland i went to
belfast i didn't see the troubles i was
too young but you look at i mentioned
often the peace wall
that separated you know the groups that
were fighting to try and stop the
violence on one side there's a monument
painting celebrating people who murdered
a bunch of other people who are like at
a restaurant like some people are
talking at a restaurant some dudes jump
and just gun them down and the other
side's like yeah you did it that's deep
tribalism when one side of the wall says
we are the true sons of israel and the
other side says we stand with palestine
i'm like what does that have to do with
the like
uk the irish republic protestantism you
know catholicism browns
it is just
rival so when you have people
they don't care
what the truth is they care that their
enemies burn and when you're in a cult
this is why i think that the biggest
threat is the establishment left and
many leftists they don't care for the
truth they don't seek out the truth they
believe lies they don't care that they
believe lies they just want pain for
them also organized religion man it's
all this is they're trying to organize a
religion around this stuff and any time
you're willing to believe something
without proof is insanity it's dangerous
and if you become zealous in your
beliefs then you become a danger you
know what i'll give you this the vatican
is corrupt beyond anything in the world
i was born and raised catholic i do
believe in god but you do hit some
points with organized religion corrupt
people take over anything they can where
they can manipulate the sheep take all
their money and buy themselves
helicopters i think the vatican's been
doing that for a really long time now
it's um davos group affiliated
individuals that the mentality of these
people is that uh i will tell you this i
have wined and dined with some of these
people i've been on rooftop parties and
their attitude is look someone's got to
work at mcdonald's and that doesn't mean
that some people you know they're just
not smart enough no no what they're
saying is we don't care if you're smart
we don't care if you're stupid we need
someone to make our burgers so whether
you're right for it or not we will make
it you
keeping people down putting themselves
in missions of power because these are
people who don't care about meritocracy
as exemplified by everything in the
culture war it's about protecting
themselves and their core group and
their assets regardless of what is
beneficial to humanity regardless of
what is true
last night i was thinking about drone
delivery and like okay biggest problem
with government what if there was a
revolution we had to reform a new
government then we'd have to be if we
were the ones in charge we'd have to
figure out where the resources are going
and make sure everyone has enough and
all of a sudden you realize we don't
have enough resources we don't have that
drone delivery like the the you will own
nothing and be happy and you'll get
everything through drones like if you
order something from amazon.com or our
website and you live in like sub-saharan
africa a drone will get thrown through
the stratosphere and orbitally drop off
your goods and then go back imagine
those going to red states people would
be blowing them out of the sky they do
they do get shot they do get shot so
that gives me it gives me a little bit
of a glimmer of okay violation that's
like a fa crime maybe shooting them down
yeah they're aircraft maybe we could
organize society maybe it could be fixed
or or resolved but then the other part
of me is just like dude it just feels
like we're on an avalanche
headed towards world economic forum
takeover where we're all like or not all
of us but the useless class which is
what you've all know harare calls these
people that are just sitting around
playing video games collecting
unemployment whatever yeah
yeah i've been there i don't understand
it i was part of that um that they just
are going to sit in the metaverse on
psychedelics that are pharmaceutically
administered be getting government
support and and maybe they're harvesting
their body no not having kids of course
they'll just be there until this is uh
are you have you played fallout one or
they'll use their reproductive organs
they might surrogacy and stuff like that
so have you played fallout one yes so uh
there's the big game that was like
groundbreaking was fallout 3 and it's a
it's a fallout series is about a
post-apocalyptic post-nuclear war and uh
um i think it's part one spoiler alert
for the 30 or whatever year old game uh
or older it's like a doom spoiler alert
yeah right so the main villain is this
uh there's a thing called the forced
evolutionary virus
that the idea was if nuclear war
happened they would give people this
virus to genetically modify them so they
could survive nuclear war it turned them
into super mutants
who were androgynous and unable to have
children
so
you come out of the vault and then like
some human survived and the main villain
at the end says
your genetics can't be allowed to
continue but i won't kill you if you if
you if if you'd like i can sterilize you
and let you let you live your life and
that's like one of the endings so what i
think we may be seeing
you know look
you can't you can't look at someone like
bill gates who goes on on stage like a
ted event and says we need to reduce
population and think
he's not trying to reduce population he
is yeah he is true we need to reduce
population now trust me to feed you and
give you drugs yes bill gates but
outside of like people being concerned
about drugs or whatever do you so when
he what he was talking about is like if
we improve technology improve healthcare
we're going to see people have less and
less kids because technological advance
advancements correlate with people
having smaller smaller families i'm not
going to get into the crazier
conspiracies about what he may be doing
with farmlands or anything like that
because he's buying a lot of farmland
but i'll say this do you think he
doesn't consider um sex ed
and like uh safe like prophylactics and
stuff as part of that campaign of course
he does of course he's thinking like how
can i get people to not have kids in
africa so
right and and so uh obviously a lot of
people like well that's okay right okay
what about when you get in the territory
of supporting organizations that
advocate for say like sterilizing
children saying like you should give
them puberty blockers which
has a high chance of or a decent chance
of you know uh inhibiting their ability
to reproduce once they get or their
desire and they lie to these families
and kids and say oh it's reversible
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you